okay because of our very special classic
interview today we're gonna dive right
into phone calls for a little bit we're
going to start with our caller from the
262 area code caller from 262 what's
going on this David Pakman this is your
on the air
oh hi David I'm such a big fan my name
is Juan Garcia on your live streams I'm
the guy who asks you the s Mary killer
question yes of course come on nice to
hear from you um I was calling because
um I was wondering if you could
resurrect somebody from the dead anybody
in history it doesn't have to be a
politician to be anybody who would it be
and why it would be just an old ancestor
of mine I would be super curious to
figure out like who is my 30th
generation grandmother or grandfather or
something like that I think that would
be fascinating I know Pat a lot of
people would probably say oh I would
resurrect some famous person or
something like that but I would be
interested in like my 30th
great-great-great grandmother or
something like that I think I would go
with Jesus Christ because I think maybe
he's the most influential person of all
time and that some people may have said
he's already resurrected yes again you
know I've given that answer before I've
been asked who would I most like to meet
from history and I've said it would be
interesting to meet Jesus just because
if we could figure out one way or the
other if he is the son of God it would
be great to just know that personally
and then we could base the rest of our
lives off of that but it would also be
great to dispel that notion if it's not
true you know one yeah I I just want to
ask you like a dumb question I'm such a
huge fan of yours and I'm not really too
well-versed in politics so I like I
don't really ask you political questions
on your live stream that's a huge fan
and yeah I'm definitely willing to learn
all that you know I definitely think
you're without a doubt the best
progressive on YouTube Wow
thank you so much all right thank you
we'll talk to you on the we'll talk to
you on the live streams a regular Pat
now David's you answer those f marry
kill questions on your live streams
that's I do I do Mike yep they're called
romantic marry ditch they
they're like kind of more politically
correct but yeah I do I do answer them